So I got a ton of tweets over the weekend
that were asking me, Hey David, are you going
to be at the straight pride,
her aide in Boston this weekend?
It's happening.
You should be there.
You should interview people.
You should counter protest or whatever because
you live in Boston anyway.
And No, I didn't go for safety reasons because
I didn't want to give it any attention.
I ended up actually being out of the city
anyway as I as I often am both during the
weekend and after the, uh, during the weekend.
But this is not an event that appealed to
me.
Um, the event happened.
There were straight pride paraders.
There were counter protesters actually more
counter protestors than paraders.
There was a massive police presence.
My contacts in law enforcement and the Intel
community told me that they were really busy
managing all of the different threats and
extremist groups that were expected to come
in.
Um, there were more people protesting the
parade, then people marching for straight
pride.
In total there were about 35 or 36 arrests
in total.
I don't know what percentage of those arrests
were marchers versus counter protesters.
I'm guessing at some point soon we will have
that information.
The markers definitely had some themes in
their messages.
Support our troops was a theme, build the
wall, was a theme.
Great.
To be straight is a theme.
A lot of pro Trump stuff.
Just make America great again in this type
of thing.
Some people were hurt, nine people ended up
at area hospitals, so people here already
know my feelings about this type of parade.
In general, a straight pride parade is unnecessary
in the sense that it's not just, if you have
a gay pride parade, then obviously everything's
fine and you should have a straight pride
parade.
The idea behind a gay pride parade is that
we're talking about a historically marginalized
and discriminated against group who's placed
in society.
A good people want to affirm most people or
straight people don't get fired for being
straight straight.
People have always been able to get married
to those to whom they are attracted.
I don't even want to dignify that part any
further.
The idea of, you know, a white pride group,
a white student union or whatever as the same
thing as a Latino student union.
Well, you're not talking about a historically
marginalized and oppressed group and we have
to really examine what the motivations are
of a lot of those groups and the motivations
aren't good.
Okay, so that that's where we're going to
stop with that analysis because it's such
a stupid analysis that it doesn't even need
to be done.
One reason I didn't go is I don't want to
give them attention.
I think counter protesting is totally valid,
but they aren't really marching for straight
pride.
They are marching to anger people.
They are marching to trigger and own the libs
as they like to say, and some of them are
marching because they genuinely struggle with
their masculinity, but that's a whole other
story which we're not going to talk about
today.
Very few of them actually show up to this
stuff to really protest and again, there were
more counter protesters this time around.
What would happen if nobody showed up to counter
protest and however many people, I don't even
know how many marchers there were.
Was it a few dozen was at a hundred people,
a couple, I don't know.
Imagine if no one gave them any attention.
They show up, they march around with their
mega hats and they're build the wall signs
and they're totally ignored.
No one protests, no one cares.
No one tries to fight the permit for the parade.
They are just ignored.
No one writes about it.
They are irrelevant.
I think that that actually is a really great
scenario.
Now again, I was out of town anyway and there
were all sorts of security concerns in terms
of some of the extremist groups that were
coming in, but these are just small groups
of people doing really dumb things.
What if we did just ignore them?
Now other perspectives are valid.
When when Bernie Sanders chose to do a Fox
News town hall, the idea being I'm going to
go right in there and talk directly to people
who might be on the right and maybe I can
convince them and Elizabeth Warren said, I'm
not going to participate at all because I
don't want to dignify.
In some sense a hate for profit Fox News and
give them ratings.
Both of those perspectives are valid.
I respect what Elizabeth Warren did and I
think Bernie Sanders crushed it in his debate,
but both are valid approaches.
In the same way you can take the perspective
that a large showing of peace and love by
counter protesters at the straight pride parade
is the best way to fight against the message
of the straight pride parade.
That's fine.
I opted for a different path and I wonder
if every time they tried to organize one of
these, they just get the permit and nobody
cares.
People go and do other things.
They go to the music, great museums in Boston.
They go to all of the different great things
that there are to do in Boston and they just
don't give any attention to these people.
Would they keep doing these parades?
Something tells me that they probably would
not.
They would not be doing this if no one paid
attention because the whole point of it is
to get attention.
So I didn't go.
I wasn't there.
I was out of the city in any case, but I would
not have gone if I was in town.
To be totally honest with you.